-You guys, our first guest
tonight is
a Grammy Award-winning
multiplatinum musician.
Her makeup line GXVE Beauty
is available now.
[ Laughter ]
At Sephora and gxvebeauty.com.
She also returns as a coach on
the new season of "The Voice,"
which premieres September 19th
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-I have toured the world.
I know how to do this show.
And it's kind of a two for one
'cause I'll just ask him
if I have questions.
[ Laughter ]
So it's fine either way.
-You wish. You wish.
-Anyways, I thought you did
a great job.
And I would love to coach you
if you want to be over here on
Team Gwen.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gwen Stefani,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back!
-This is so --
I feel like the last couple
of years just evaporated.
It's been like two years.
-I know.
Well, we've seen each other
on Zoom.
You've been kind enough
to do the show that way.
But it's been three years since
you've been here in person.
-Three years, oh, my gosh.
-It's so nice to have you back.
-That's so crazy.
-How has your summer been?
I know you were on the road
with Blake. How's that?
-It's been really fun.
And it's something I never
thought would ever happen to me.
We actually -- He invited me
to be on a couple of his tracks.
A couple duets or whatever.
And they went to number one
country radio, so --
-Yeah. I guess you wouldn't have
predicted even 10 years ago --
-I wouldn't predicted
ever meeting Blake Shelton,
let alone being on the road with
him and hopping on his stage.
It's been really fun.
-And so, obviously, Blake --
I feel like Blake and No Doubt
maybe have different fan bases.
But are there times --
Does he --
-You'd be surprised.
-Yeah.
-We're definitely
cross-pollinating.
-That's good.
-Yeah.
-Do you ever do
any of your songs
when you're on the road
with Blake?
-You know what?
He asks me
to do songs all the time.
And I'm like,
"It's not my stage."
Like, "This is so awkward."
Like I'm forcing myself like,
"I want some attention.
Let me be on your --"
It's not.
But he wants me to come on.
And sometimes I'll do, like,
"Don't Speak."
-Yeah.
-And it's pretty incredible
to be able to have a song that
you get out there and you think,
"Do they know me? Are they going
to be like, 'Why is she here?'"
Then they know all the words.
You're like, "Oh, my God.
This is crazy."
-That's great.
I mean, I guess with songs
that iconic, they do cross over,
you know,
all genre of fan I guess.
-That song is just --
it's that song
that just went everywhere.
-And I would imagine
you might be thinking,
"I'm not here
to steal your focus."
But I would imagine an audience
loses their mind
when they think, "I'm lucky
enough I'm getting two for one."
-Well, I feel like --
We were up in, like, Canada,
somewhere I never even heard of.
And I'm like --
I wasn't even going to go up.
I'm like, "Not today."
I was like, "How do I not?"
You know?
I'm never going to be there
again, so I do it.
-Do you get worried when you've
never heard of a place
that you're going to be like,
"Are you ready to rock?"
and then forget
the name of the place?
[ Laughter ]
-All the time.
I'm scared I'm going to forget
your name right now
at this point.
[ Laughter ]
-Just say, "Hey, buddy."
I respond to that really well.
-Okay.
-So, you have not done a couple
seasons of "The Voice."
But the last one you did,
you won.
-Winner! Yep.
-Yeah, congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you feel more relaxed
having a win like that,
a recent win under your belt?
-Winning is fun.
I think the thing --
The way I won was amazing
because I actually had
a 14-year-old boy.
And he was a one-chair turn.
So, these ears heard a star.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That's really nice.
-It was cool.
And he turned 15 on the show.
And, you know, when you see him
now, his name is Carter Rubin.
Check him out. He's incredible.
He's just grown before my eyes
like he's my kid.
And he's blossomed, and --
So yeah, I mean,
we don't really win.
It's them who win. But it was
really fun to coach him.
-I don't know.
You definitely said "winner"
real quick and did this thing.
-That is true.
[ Laughter ]
-I really feel like you're
changing the narrative.
And we were all here
when you did that.
[ Laughter ]
-It does feel good to have one
under my belt when I go back.
There's no way to compete with
Blake Shelton.
-Yes. But it must be nice, yeah.
-It's fun to rub it in
when I come back, yeah.
-He seems very -- He seems to be
someone who both enjoys
the rubbing
and the being rubbed against.
-I love rubbing him.
It's so fun. He's rubbable.
-So, you obviously,
before No Doubt's time,
you had been doing music
forever.
So you were never in a situation
where you had to audition
for anyone the way
"The Voice" singers do.
-That's true.
I always think about that.
I did audition to be
a cheerleader in high school,
and I didn't make it.
-You didn't? Really?
-Didn't even make the first --
I can't believe
they even let me try out.
I tried out. I really just
wanted to wear the outfit.
-Sure.
-That was the whole thing.
So, I kind of made up for it.
-Did you know
while you were auditioning,
"This isn't going well"?
-I knew that I wasn't able to do
choreography like that.
I couldn't remember. Remember,
we just talked about that?
-Yeah.
-So, I had a hard time
remembering the moves, and --
but yeah --
-It did work out. You found
a different way into the outfit.
-I got the outfit.
-In the "Hollaback" video.
Do you think that
the cheerleading coach saw this
and was like,
"You went around --
you didn't go through
proper channels!"
-I don't even know.
I do think about that.
I wonder who that person was,
and if they were like,
"Wow, she cheated her way
to the top."
[ Laughter ]
-But now you're also --
Marching band costume as well.
-Yes.
-Were you in marching band?
-I was. I was a band geek.
And I fake-played the piccolo
for a long time.
-Okay, so, what do you mean
by fake played?
-Well, I'm not a liar.
But I definitely
couldn't really --
-A lot of the time you spend
telling us what you're not.
-I cheated.
[ Laughter ]
-You've also told us
what you are.
-Okay, well, I did --
-You cheated?
-I just never could get the hang
of playing that instrument.
-And they just never noticed
you were fake playing?
-There's a lot of people
in the band, right?
And I was a piccolo!
-Do you feel like this is
a problem across marching bands
across America,
that there are just
a lot of piccolo players
who are just faking it?
-I hope not.
I had a lot of fun doing that,
though. That was incredible.
I wanted to be the dancer,
but I was in a band uniform.
-Gotcha. Well, that's a good way
to start.
'Cause there is some -- I mean,
I'm not being insincere.
There is a lot of choreography
for marching bands as well.
-It's a lot of choreography.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and I cannot dance.
People think that I can dance,
but I just fake that as well.
-Well, you're very good
at all of this.
-I'm very sneaky, yeah.
-Are you really married
to Blake Shelton?
[ Laughter ]
Because it looks that way on TV.
-This is a fake diamond ring.
-I got more to ask you. We'll be
right back with Gwen Stefani.